let's define a few familiar and standard
operations on sets so here's a picture
of two sets a and B where the idea is
that the circle represents the points in
a the other circle represents the points
in B the overlapping area of this lens
shaped region are the points that are in
both a and B and the background are the
points that are in either a and B so
this is sort of a general picture allows
you to classify points with respect to a
and B and it's called a Venn diagram in
this case for two sets it's still useful
for three sets it gets more complicated
for four sets and after about that after
that point they're not really very
useful but a lot of the basic operations
can be illustrated nicely in terms of
the Venn diagram for two sets and that's
we're about to do so the first operation
is Union it's the set of points shown
here in magenta it's the set of points
that are in either A or B all of them
and so if we were defining this as a in
terms of set theoretic notation or
predicate notation the Union symbol the
U is for the Union symbol so a union B
is defined to be those points X that are
in a or are in B and you can already
begin to see an intimate relationship
between the Union operation and the
propositional or connective but don't
confuse them if you apply an or two sets
you're compiler is going to give you a
type error and if you apply Union to
propositional variables your compiler is
also going to give you a type error so
let's keep the propositional operators
and the set theoretic operators separate
although and clearly distinct even
though they resemble each other all
right
next basic operation is intersection
where again it's the points that are
both in a and B the points in common
which are now highlighted in blue so the
definition of a intersection B we use an
upside-down Union symbol for an
intersection it's the set of points that
are in a and are in B so let's stop for
a minute and make use of the similarity
between the set theoretic operations and
the propositional operators
let's look at a set theoretic identity
which I claim holds no matter what sets
a B and C you're talking about and we're
going to prove it by making the
connection between set theoretic
operations and propositional operations
so let's read the thing it says that if
you take a Union the set B intersection
C that's equal to the set a union B
intersected with a union C now let's not
think through yet how to make this an
intuitive argument it's gonna really
crank out in an automatic way in a
moment but we can remember it as saying
that you can think of this as Union
distributing over intersection so where
if you think of Union as times here and
intersection is plus then we're we've
got a rule that says that a times B plus
C is 8 times B plus a times C now it's
also true that if you reverse the role
of Union an intersection you get another
distributive law that and distributes
over Union but never mind that let's
just look at this one we're trying to
prove the distributive law for union
over intersection how shall we prove it
just from the definitions well the way
we're gonna do it is by showing that the
two sets on the left-hand side and the
right-hand side have the same set of
elements namely if I have an element X
that appears in the set described on the
left-hand side then it's that point is
on the right-hand side and it's an if
and only if so that says that the
left-hand side and the right-hand side
expressions define sets with the same
set of points this holds for all X and
that turns out that the proof is gonna
follow from by analogy to a
propositional formula that we're going
to make use of in the proof that was a
propositional equivalence that we proved
in an earlier talk namely that or
distributes over and so P or Q and R is
equivalent to P or Q and P or R so you
can see the
this equivalence has the same structure
as in this equivalence in purple has the
same structure as the set theoretic
equality in blue except that unions
replaced by Killoran intersections
replaced by and and set variables ABC is
replaced by propositional variables P Q
R so let's just remember that we've
already proved this propositional
equivalence and we're gonna make use of
it in the middle of this proof that
these two sets are equal so again we
said we were going to prove that two
sets are equal by showing they have the
same points so here's the proof it's
gonna be a lovely if and only if
argument the whole way so looking at the
left hand side and a point X is in a
union B intersection C by definition of
Union if and only if X is in a or X is
in B intersection C I've just applied
the definition of Union there okay now
let's look at this expression X is in B
intersection C that's the same as X is
in B and X is in C again just using the
definition of intersection and now I
have a propositional formula involving
or and and and the basic assertions
about sets of X is a member of one of
those ABCs now at this point I can
immediately apply my propositional
equivalence and say that the assertion X
is in a or X is in B and X is in C is
holds if and only if this expression X
is in a or X is in B and X is in a or
X's and C why is that well I'm just
invoking the propositional equivalence
let's look at it that if I think of the
X is in a as proposition P and let's
replace all the x over a is by P and I
think of X is in B as a Q and X is and C
is an R then I can see that the the
first set theoretic assertion has the
form of p or q and r and i can transform
it by the propositional equivalence into
P or Q and P or R and then remember what
p and r are to get back to the set
theoretic membership basic
Bishop assertions so now we've just
proved that X is in a or X's and B and X
is in a or X's and C and then that's if
and only if it was in the left hand side
set well now I'm gonna go back the other
way
namely this or that X is in a or X's and
B is the same as saying that X is in a
union B likewise here it just might
apply the definition of Union and this
assertion that X is in this set and X is
in this set is the same as saying that X
is in there intersection and I've just
proved I've completed my proof namely
the point that was in the left hand side
is if and only if it's in the right hand
side you have to remember that that was
the right hand side of the identity so
this is a general method actually where
you can take any set theoretic equality
involving Union and intersection and the
operations of difference and complement
that we'll talk about in a moment and we
can convert any such set theoretic
equality into a propositional equality
or propositional equivalence or we can
check that it that the propositional
assertion is an equivalence and from
that using this method of converting the
membership statements in the set
expression into a propositional
combination we can check and
automatically check any kind of set
theoretic identity involving Union
intersection well and - and that in fact
is the way that automatic engines like
Mathematica can prove these set
theoretic identities so let's just for
the record put down that last operation
the difference operation is the set of
elements that are in a and not in B so
we'd write it as a minus B is the set of
points that are in a and not in B and
it's illustrated by this region that's
highlighted in orange and a special case
of the minus operation of the difference
operation is complement when you know
the overall domain that you expect all
your sets to be part of then you can
define a complement to be everything
that's not in a
a set of X such that X is not in a where
X is understood to be ranging over some
domain of this course so if you're going
to picture that we're looking at the
whole orange region all of the stuff
that's not in a if we think of the whole
slide as representing the domain of
discourse D